if you're trying to get your act
together it's really important to
stretch yourself out and and sit up
properly
it's like a need for three ways to do it
three ways you can execute this on a
regular basis to get into that happy
positive zone if you don't have a
healthy body a healthy mind there's no
way in hell you'll be able to sustain
the stress the the pressure it takes to
be successful rise and shine it's an
espresso time what's up Philippe nation
it's Evan my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
stand up straight
over to you Jordan B Peterson stand up
straight with your shoulders back and my
wife is a massage therapist and she's
very physiologically aware so she's also
helped me with this sort of thing but we
watch people on the streets all the time
people in general now have very poor
posture yeah very bad for them well
that's four that's got to be phone
related - right well yeah I think that's
part of it but I also think it's
something our culture doesn't attend to
like you kind of have to remind your
kids to stand up you know it takes a
certain amount of conscious effort but
yeah in that chapter I talked a lot
about lobsters which I'm going to I kind
of have an affinity for lobsters and
because they well the short story is
that when a lobster loses a fight
because they're fighting all the time
for dominance let's say in their
hierarchies
he kind of crunches down so he looks
smaller when he wins a fight he
stretches out looks bigger and so he's
signaling to other lobsters the tally of
his victories and then say so if a
lobster has won a fight he's more likely
to win the next fight then you would
calculate from having a tally of all his
previous defeats and victories and if he
loses a fight then he's more likely to
lose the next fight so that's that that
Mathieu principle at work mm-hmm okay so
you think well so what so what does that
have to do with
anything it's like okay part of the
kicker is well that lobster runs on
serotonin neurochemical and if the
lobster loses the serotonin levels go
down and if he wins the serotonin levels
go up and when the serotonin levels go
up he stretches out and he's a confident
lobster and one of the consequences of
that is if a lobster loses a battle and
you give him the equivalent of
antidepressants then he stretches out
and he'll go fight again so
antidepressants work on lobsters huh
right and you think well who cares it's
like no no you don't get it we diverged
from lobsters from an evolutionary
perspective three hundred and fifty
million years ago and it's the same
circuit it's absolutely unbelievable and
that shows you how deep inside you how
basic how primordial that circuit isn't
you that's sizing other people up and
looking at where they fit in the
hierarchy well with human society it's
more like hierarchies of confidence than
dominance per se but and like if your
serotonin levels fall you get depressed
you crunch forward and and the whole
everything around you turns cloudy and
black and and then you're inviting more
oppression right and so you get into
this bad loop you know and so it's
really important to if you're trying to
get your act together it's really
important to stretch yourself out and
and sit up properly because it's it's
part of the psychophysiological loop
that can start you on the upward curve
and so it's a really important thing to
take note of and the fastest way to
change your emotion is to change your
body if you are down if you're feeling
negative you have low self confidence if
you're a walk around like this the
fastest way to get your brain to trigger
to be happy to be productive to be
optimistic I think is to change your
body the thing that I do is I put on
music I have a belief playlist I put on
music it's songs to get me fired up to
get me moving and really the criteria is
anything that gets me bouncing moving I
want to shake I want to I got a shake
off the crappy feeling of the morning or
whatever just happened to me even coming
here today coming here to TDS we are so
so sorry filming at 8:30 I got here
7:45 setting up I had low energy last
night was a late night they didn't sleep
that well and I came here and I'm
thinking I need this is this is a really
important day for me I need to make
great videos for believe nation right I
care about you guys I want to try to be
at my best and so recognizing that my
emotional state wasn't the best I come
in I put on music I blast them on these
loudspeakers we got great speakers here
TDs and I started dancing I start moving
I start instantly changing how I'm
feeling and so any time that you feel
yourself in a negative spot feeling Low
Energy you feeling lethargic even if you
catch yourself saying negative things
about yourself or not believing in
yourself anymore before talking yourself
into a positive mental state I think
what you should do is move your body
stand up straight put some music on when
you change your body it's a fastest way
to change your emotional state so I can
give you three ways to do it three ways
you can execute this on a regular basis
to get into that happy positive zone
number one is make a playlist so I have
what I call the belive playlist it's
actually a public playlist on my youtube
channel so you guys can check it out
it's just called hashtag believe and in
there are songs that I love just songs
that make me want to move making one of
Bounce you may not like any of the songs
it's not about having the perfect song
it's what the perfect song is for you I
also find that it can't just be the same
songs every single time if you just
listen to that same song on repeat for
the next year it'll lose its efficacy
you may start to annoy you listen to
that song so much so having a playlist
of different songs so that whenever you
feel low whenever you need energy
whenever you feel like you're slouching
and you're not happy you're in a bad
spot put it on a song that makes you
happy that makes you want to move and
shake will instantly move you to a more
happy place and then you can take
positive action
so today make a playlist if you have
your one word call it your one word like
creativity or love or believe or
whatever it is and if you're still
trying to figure it out just call it
call it escape from negativity playlist
that's your playlist and then today make
a list of 25 to 50 different songs that
you love that make you move and just
test like when you play that song what
do you do if you are not moving some
part of your body when that's
comes on it doesn't count does not make
the list go through put 25 to 50 songs
on there set that up once and you can
keep adding to it later but we set it up
once today and so anytime you're any
negative spot you play any song from
that playlist and it will lift you up
tip number two is create a three times a
day reminder for any of these things
that you want to have it's it may be
easy to capture in the moment so you
might feel like I'm depressed I'm sad
I'm negative and then it triggers you to
create the playlist and listen to it but
you may not always catch it and so
having a reminder whether that's on your
phone that pops up or with us in your
Google Calendar or whatever you're using
somewhere you're gonna see it three
times a day if you want to stand up
straight more often put that as a
reminder three times a day look at 8
a.m. or whenever you first get to your
office look at lunchtime and look at
just before you go home so if you look
in the 8 a.m. one o'clock and 5 o'clock
as an example three times a day little
thing pops up that says stand up
straight or sit up straight just even
talking about it myself I'm standing up
more straight and so having that in your
reminder on a regular basis otherwise
it's easy to fall back into your old
patterns but boom three times a day it's
gonna pop up and you're gonna take the
action and you will feel better and
number three is use a buddy system
I love having some built-in
accountability find somebody who will
keep you accountable and you can do it
for each other around standing up
straight or around getting that
negativity I use it for negative
comments I use it for complaining I tell
the people closest to me if you ever
hear me complaining about something and
I don't reframe it - this is the best
like this is awesome we're gonna find a
way through it if you ever hear that
from me I want you to call me up because
I might be able to catch it myself I'm
trying to do a better job at catching
things myself I might have the reminders
built-in that three times a day I'm
being reminded about this thing but
still you're not gonna catch the other
moments and so if you have a buddy
somebody who you're with a good chunk of
the day or could be colleague at work or
somebody on your team at work it could
be your husband or wife at home your
boyfriend a girlfriend or your kids my
son loves calling me out on things
having that buddy system built-in as
well to enforce the behavior that you
want to
and so if it's standing up straight if
anybody sees you slouching say call me
up right or like take your ruler and hit
me on the back
having somebody called the behavior out
when you don't catch it yourself now
I've got a really special bonus gift for
you but before that question of the day
I want to know what is this song that
lifts your spirits what is this song
that you need to bounce to every time it
comes on I'm gonna check out some of
them and maybe add to my own belief
playlist as well so let me know the song
that lifts you out of negativity put in
the description below put it not in
description put it in the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso and enjoy the bonus
[Music]
I saw a couple comments on YouTube
people asking or Dan do you recommend
these like mine stimulating our mind and
hinting drugs the answer is absolutely
not
if you follow my work you know I don't
smoke I don't drink and I don't do drugs
I don't even drink coffee why I drink
like honey green tea that's why I drink
and water and maybe from time to time
you know cook zero when I'm watching a
movie or something like that that's it
no drugs no cigarettes and no alcohol
why is that because you notice a lot of
times even with my own story my father
was actually a very heavy smoker I want
to say he said hey he was an alcoholic
but he drinks quite a bit he enjoys a
glass here and there and I do notice
later on when he had to stroke he had
all the when his health was in it was
declining a lot of those habits
contributed to that if you don't have a
healthy body a healthy mind there's no
way in hell you'll be able to sustain
the stress the the pressure it takes to
be successful so I don't think you need
those things you only need those mind
enhancing drugs to be successful to have
more clarity and all this if you want to
enjoy a drink here and there that's
perfectly fine I'm just saying I don't
do it I don't need to have alcohol to
have a good time and when I drink I like
people hey Dan just a zip of beer it's
okay enjoy they don't taste good to me
quite frankly even they taste like pop
right they don't even taste it to me so
I don't enjoy I don't need those things
to have a good time if I have a good
time good company good friends good
conversation I have a good time and I
don't need to get high to do to I get
high on doing what I love I get high on
just life I get high on being the impact
to people altruistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so
I wanted to think and see it's a bloody
brief life all of you have the potential
for enormous success if you want to know
what Gary v-d-j khalid oprah and others
know about empire building that most
people miss check out the link in the
description for a free bonus video